[Music]
in this video
we're going to walk through how to add
change or delete a billing account from
a google cloud project using the console
in order to perform these tasks you'll
need to be a project owner or project
billing manager on the project
and a billing account administrator or
billing account user for the target
billing account
get started by heading into the cloud
console you can start on any project
home page
then head to the navigation menu in the
left-hand pane choose billing
and then click manage billing accounts
you can also access the same destination
from the billing overview page by
expanding the drop-down list of billing
accounts
and clicking on manage billing accounts
select the my projects tab to view a
list of your projects
you'll also see the associated cloud
billing account for each project
if you have a project for which billing
is currently disabled you can re-enable
it by clicking on the three-dot menu
and selecting change billing in the drop
down
choose the desired billing account and
click set account
you can also change the billing account
currently attached to a project
following a similar process
identify the project and click the three
dot menu and select
change billing in the drop down choose
the desired destination billing account
and click
set account if you would like to remove
a billing account from a project or in
other words
disable billing identify the project and
click the three dot menu
then select disable billing you'll be
asked to confirm that you want to
disable billing for this project
a quick word of caution disabling
billing on a project might cause some
resources to be removed
and become non-recoverable when you are
ready click disable billing
if at any time the options to change
billing or disable billing are not
available to you
this means you may not have the
permissions needed to make this change
in that case be sure to review the
permissions requirements shared at the
beginning of this video
head over to the documentation to check
out more details
you